one of country music's hottest couples
is officially married that's right
Michael ray and Carly Pierce tie the
knot during an intimate ceremony just
outside of Nashville last weekend the
pair confirm the news two people
reported they married at Drake wood farm
in front of about a hundred family
members and friends while they
originally planned for an outdoor
ceremony the rain had ideas of its own
and moved their I Do's into one of the
rustic barns but that didn't stop their
dream wedding from taking place with
Carly revealing to people quote honestly
it was more magical and way more
romantic than I think it would have been
outside and Michael agreed adding it was
an old barn from the 1850s and we had
all our family there and with the rain
falling it made it a little more magical
Carly surprised Michael with a Samantha
Sleeper non-traditional wedding gown
featuring a high neckline and short
pencil skirt with a sheer lace overlay
but she changed into a custom Hayley
Paige masterpiece to get her dancing on
for the reception and boy did they ever
get their dancing on they even kept the
party going into the late night heading
to the Nashville palace a honky-tonk bar
that just happens to be where they had
their first dates now the couple first
bonded over their love for Nashville's
Grand Ole Opry so fittingly the ceremony
was officiated by Bill Cody and
announcer at the Opry Charlie said he
perfectly reflected their love for
traditional country selling people quote
it just feels special because it's kind
of all-encompassing of country music and
the Opry and our story and as any
songwriter would the pair read vows
written by themselves which is so
romantic the country singers may not
have performed themselves but Jake Owen
was in attendance to sing his ballad
made through you for the couple's first
dance and back at boots and hearts in
August Michael told us how he asked Jake
to do the honor and I was like holy crap
this is it you know so I texted to Carly
right away and I was like hey Jake oh
and made for you she's like what no it's
like it's the song we got it you just
got to hear it so she heard it and
agreed and then I did a show with Jake
at two weeks after I said hey man our
first dance is made for you it's gonna
be made for you he's like no way I said
yeah and then I was like don't shoot on
this chance like you know drunk because
he was up on it was up on our bus and I
was like maybe
maybe cool if you never gonna be that
guy that's like asking your friends come
work the wedding you know
Sasa a man be cool if you could maybe
you know coming and to do it and he's
like I've never been a wedding singer
he's like I'm totally and then I was
like awesome it just it worked out great
but it wasn't always easy coming to
agreement on every little detail with
both country stars telling us a few of
their struggles that came with planning
the big day ask her if I can get three
more people to the way when I talked to
Michael I said what question should I
ask Carly okay so his question is can he
have three more people come to the
wedding it's been difficult with sweet
Michael having a huge family and as we
go along I gave him a cutoff and as
we've gotten closer there's little
special people that just all of a sudden
is showing up that I have no idea who
they are but they're so important to it
right I'm pretty sure I granted you
those three people last week better not
be what I heard it's mostly her and her
mom they're planning at the wedding yeah
do they've got everything they've done
every day I have what cuz I have been
involved someo because I was like I
don't wanna be a dude it's like oh I
don't want to do I just don't want to
show up for the most part I just said we
have to have an open bar and we have to
make sure that my groomsmen attire is
simple if we just do like a other like I
got like an upscale restaurant look you
know good white shirt wow it's like we
get we can top it you know sir
they can serve yet servitude everything
I said we've I'm sorry asking some of my
buddies to start getting three-piece
suits so they're gonna be out here out
your day line you said he just wanted an
open bar and he wanted like simple
outfits for
i granted em both okay good but I mean
it sounds like they both got what they
wanted in the end right as for their
future they both know marriage has its
ups and downs especially with their busy
schedules we are not naive to think that
marriage will bring its abs and flows
and ups and downs and things like that
but at the end of the day I hope that in
50 years I can look at this person and
love him more than I do now which is a
whole lot but for now it's back to work
as Carly continues the fall portion on
Jason Aldean's ride all night tour with
Kane Brown and for Michael he's about to
headline CMT on tour this fall but come
December they'll be jetting off to the
sandals resort in Jamaica so or sure
this honeymoon will be worth the wait so
what did you think of their whimsical
Nashville wedding let us know in the
comments below
[Music]
[Music]